you have Christmas beverages oh yeah
glühwein what is it glue bond yes pretty
much sharpshooter Wow
it's very very popular half those people
just felt bad for you okay thank you for
your pity party you Elysee yes Oh
jealousy I'll get the girl what is it
where is it glue find blue vine blue
vine to vine yeah yeah vine so in
gluhwein we had many ingredients there's
wine and and there's some who cares it's
- in it and you you make it warm and you
chug a lucky lucky because as you know
the children are now screaming and
terrified because of all the monsters
yes and as an adult you need to feel
more calming so so what you're saying in
Germany is you terrify the children then
the parents get drunk so they don't care
absolutely then they don't hear the
screams of their children yes - speak up
- screams and glue vines I think we've
been preparing some proof you have some
gluhwein
yes yes during it for the less alright
let's bring out some gluhwein i think we
have a wonderful
I also have some snacks AB snack yeah B
so you have there in your crotch you
thought this it's not my crotch coming
into my pelvis okay um these are late
coupon these are Christmas cookie
Christmas cookie yeah you I have
chocolate and also not chocolate okay
I'll have chocolate what would you like
I guess I'll take the not chocolate oh
you dirty dog
oh and now we did you already know I
already ate the crack was that wrong to
eat the cookie is a cookie and stare at
the eyeballs okay what do we say we say
who have I not in hot hot 4 9 and hacked
oh yeah this is that a real thing I just
said no I invented it's true very good
no please from now we drink this please
mrs. King
this is hot wine is that what you're
saying yeah we call it guru vine which
means glowing wine but don't worry it's
no uranium in this who says that before
having a drink why would I why would I
think there would be uranium in this
well if it is the glowing like the noble
gases have you heard of neon mm-hmm I
see you have listen there's a four
valence of electron listen I want to
congratulate you're under the movie
Ferdinand oh thank you so much coming up
we're going to bring that up
no you up save a picture of you on the
red carpet yes we do and this is you
what you wore on the red carpet at the
Ferdinand movie you haven't do you have
a lot of I like your style you are who
you are fluid there's no changing it now
don't stop it it's too late what what a
great slogan to have for your life you
know it
and is in theaters on Friday Flula Borg
so nice to see you again
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you